kommt jetzt die wende im krieg gegen die
russischen truppen von kreml tyrann
vladimir putin die ukrainischen
streitkräfte haben nach eigenen angaben
die angekündigte gegen offensive im
süden des landes gestartet es geht dabei
um die gegend rund um die großstadt
person die gegenoffensive der ukraine im
süden des landes an mindestens einer
stelle habe man die russische front
durchbrochen das meldet der ukrainische
generalstab
und wir sprechen jetzt mit bild vize
paul ronzheimer der gerade in greven ist
paul schmidt morgen dir wenn die
russischen soldaten überleben wollen
dann ist es jetzt in der zeit nach hause
zu gehen das sagt ukraine präsident
selensky was weißt du alles über diese
gegenoffensive
also man muss erst einmal feststellen
dass diese gegen offensive tatsächlich
stattgefunden hat und immer noch
stattfindet denn seit monaten wird
darüber geredet dass die ukraine dort
zurück schlagen wollen und jetzt ist es
tatsächlich so offen ist wie erfolgreich
diese offensive ist was wir hören von
unseren quellen ist dass es eine
bestätigung gibt für den durchbruch an
einer stelle das mindestens vier dörfer
erobert worden sein sollen und dass man
weiter richtungstasten das ist die
großstadt im süden die anfang märz
erobert worden ist die symbolisch so
wichtig ist auch für die ukraine und
wirtschaftlich das ist das ziel man will
person ob man das am ende schafft dass
es offen es gibt berichte auch bereits
über hohe opferzahlen auf der
ukrainischen seite was dann normales
wenn es einen angriff gibt also der
angreifende ist in dem moment immer im
nachteil tatsächlich hat aber die taktik
mit heimers waffen in den vergangenen
wochen munitionsdepots zu zerstören und
die russen dort schwach zu machen war
offenbar erfolgreich momentan ist alles
was dort an der front passiert
geheimsache wir journalisten werden
nicht an die direkte front durchgelassen
selbst militär journalisten die
sozusagen embedded für die ukrainische
armee arbeiten sind nicht mit dort an
der front deswegen ist es sehr sehr
schwierig unabhängige
berichte von dort zu bekommen ist diese
situation er weiter für uns im blick
behalten man ist im moment sehr
vorsichtig mit informationen sagt paul
ronzheimer und zugeschaltet aus der
ukraine paul wir müssen auch noch über
andere wenig sprechen er hat nicht mehr
lange zeit hier in deutschland aber eher
zeit genug noch mal schlagzeilen zu
machen erst ging es um den
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann der
wurde ausgeladen und jetzt geht es um
ein bier sag uns genau was sind die
hintergründe es gibt mal wieder kurz vor
seiner rückkehr in die ukraine reichlich
stoff für schlagzeilen um andrej melik
ja es in diesem fall nicht andere wenig
der unbedingt für die direkte
schlagzeile sorgt sondern ein cdu
abgeordneter aus dem bundestag der seine
ausweisung gefordert hat und gesagt hat
das fass sei übergelaufen und daraufhin
hat anderem wenig der ukrainische
botschafter gesagt was für ein tier muss
man eigentlich getrunken haben um so
etwas zu sagen angesichts der russischen
aggression und ja du hast recht
wahrscheinlich war noch kein botschafter
in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
jahrzehnten so häufig in den
schlagzeilen wie andrej melik und
erschafft das auch in den letzten wochen
aber auch eben durch seine gegner die
nicht nur bei fdp und linken also bei
denjenigen die pro putin eingestellt
sind
sind sondern auch bei der cdu also bei
einem cdu bundestagsabgeordneten
hans einmal vielen herzlichen dank für
deine informationen an diesem morgen
direkte aus der ukraine
[Musik]